[Music]
the arrival of more than 400 happy
Jamaicans they've come to seek work in
Britain and are ready and willing to do
any kind of job that will help the
motherland along the road to prosperity
75 years ago coming into Port HMT Empire
Windrush they're all full of Hope for
the future onits were a thousand and
twenty seven passengers plus two stories
it made the long journey from Kingston
Jamaica to Tilbury docks in London so
let's make them very welcome as they
begin their new life but here
[Music]
the Windrush arrival became symbolic of
that generation of Commonwealth citizens
he came to live here in Britain between
1948 and
1973. the Windra stood for the
dissolution of that familiar Colonial
environment the Windrush stood for a new
kind of Adventure but it was a
generation let down by the British
government a handful of years ago it
emerged that many had been wrongly
detained denied legal rights threatened
with deportation and in at least 83
cases wrongly deported from the UK by
the home office in what became known as
the Windrush Scandal let me be clear Mr
Speaker there is nothing that I can say
today which will undo the pain the
suffering and the misery inflicted upon
the Windrush generation
I'm Neil Patterson and on this edition
of The Sky News Daily I'm joined by Sir
Trevor Phillips he's made a documentary
Windrush and us about the impact that
generation made on British life and
culture
tell me what you remember of the actual
Voyage coming here most of the time
Bible gambling
most of the time that's right that's
what I did this is Alfred Gardner a
passenger who made that Voyage on Empire
Windrush what were you playing at poker
poker okay yeah most but most of the
time
but it was a happy trip in your mind did
you ever think you would still be here
75 years later no not a chance of that
because I mean I planned to come here
and work five years
that was my plan five years
earn enough money to go back
good hands
what a long five years
the cost of the passage was 28 pounds
yeah at the time so it's a lot of money
a lot of money it was a hell of a lot of
money
was it worth it every penny yeah to me
every penny
Trevor great to have you on the podcast
so start by telling me about the Britain
that existed back in 1948 the Britain
that welcomed the HMT Empire Windrush
this was three years after the end of
the war
this was a country that was pretty much
exhausted it was gray and it was short
of everything including people to do the
rebuilding three weeks after the Empire
Windrush landed the National Health
Service came into being India had become
independent the year before and the
empire was really seeing its final days
and so when these young people arrived
some of them who had been here before
because they'd fought in the War
particularly in the RAF they saw this
sort of worn out country but with the
seeds of some new possibilities uh and I
think it was a latter that they were
really embracing to to what extent could
you have described the Britain pre-wind
rushes as diverse you know there's a
sort of a slight historical Amnesia here
I mean it wasn't the first time anybody
in Britain had seen Black Folk
um it's worth saying that maybe 150
years ago before that there had been a
really thriving black community in
London mainly of runaway slaves from the
American Civil War because a lot of
slaves fought on the side of the British
because the British had promised them
that they would abolish slavery so it
wasn't the first time black folk had
been here but it was certainly the first
time they'd come in numbers and it was
certainly the first time that they had
come if you like and been part of the
general population and visible in the
way that they were in 1948 and and
onwards one of the things that my own
father said that when he arrived that uh
by train from Southampton the thing that
really surprised him was to see a white
man sweeping the platform at the station
because where he came from that would
never have been possibility but of
course you put yourself in your father's
position and of course it would have
seemed strange of course it would have
seemed otherworldly I'm the 10th to 10
children I was the one who was born here
the others came with my parents on boat
in 1950 a bit after the wind crash
landed but they were part of that first
wave it's now you know commonly said
that they were poor people looking for
jobs and that they answered the call
that is true a bit later but I think
what is important about that first group
is that they chose to come to Britain
they had fought in the war they'd seen
their classmates killed on bombing raids
and so on you know and some of them had
done heroic service but actually the
other thing about them was that they
were adventurous all of them really were
people who
wanted to have something different
something better for their lives and
that's why they got on boats and made
that 30-day journey I mean Travelers as
you've alluded to Windrush certainly
wasn't the only boat they came across
and it certainly in fact wasn't wasn't
even wasn't even the first so so why why
do you think that it that it has had it
has had such an impact through the years
why do so many people associate that
generation with that name getting a lot
of cameras to go and film the arrival of
a boat in 1948 would have been quite a
big deal
um and you know getting Lord Kitchener
to sing his song London is a place for
me and all of that I think that people
began to be worried about how many
people would come how would they fit in
what were they coming for and so on and
of course that was the time when you
know all Imperial citizens had the same
passport so there was no barrier to
people coming these were not really
immigrants in the way that we think of
them today they send up warship to
Shadow Windrush so it became a sort of
coarse celeb in the end the name
Windrush has really become a British
story rather than a story of uh the
Caribbean
um it is in if you like the origin story
of a part of the British
population of black Britain which I've
just talked to us then a little bit
about the the initial reception that
those coming off the boats had I mean
this this was a post-war period it was
the deprivation that comes with that and
of course the trauma that comes that
comes in the aftermath of a war as well
how was it for that first generation we
shouldn't be naive about it these people
were not stupid they were they they knew
some of what was likely to occur of
course they'd lived in colonies and you
know few societies are more hierarchical
and racially divided than Colonial
societies and that was certainly
the uh the experience that I had as a
child grow growing up but when you talk
to people of that generation they will
always say
boy it was cold and they mean that it
was cold climatically the temperature
but they also meant that their neighbors
were called to them and that
um they weren't for a long time not so
much that any people were tremendously
hostile though that was true in some
cases Teddy Boys would Chase my brother
home from school every day but by and
large uh the the British thing of Live
and Let Live has a which is generally
positive in my view but has a negative
thing which is we're going to leave you
alone we're not going to be particularly
friendly to to you because you've got
your funny ways and we don't understand
them but we don't have to talk to you so
there was quite a lot of cold
shouldering and you know when we moved
in the street people would move out and
all of that I think that the point at
which things
change was when everybody realized both
the migrant the Caribbean voyages and
also everybody else that we weren't
going home because remember most of the
people who came on the boat thought
they'd come make some money and go home
in five years when they started to have
children their children went to school
here and weren't going to move and so on
I think everybody suddenly eventually
thought whoa we're known that we're now
in a different place and that's the
point at which things started to change
in some ways they got uglier But
ultimately they got better you were
after a while but after a fashion there
were no longer signs up saying no dogs
no blacks no Irish but that does not in
and of itself mean that the way in which
people were treated by systems by
institutions was not itself overtly
racist I mean it's worth saying that
didn't happen without struggle in 1963
the British Bristol bruss company
said overtly that it would not employ
black bus conductors because white
passengers particularly women would be
afraid to travel with them at night and
nobody and I mean nobody objected to
this and it was only after a boycott
that lasted months led by Paul Stevenson
that the bus company relented and
changed its policy and we started to
make things a bit different but out of
that boycott came the first
anti-discrimination legislation in 1965
but uh introduced by labor government
under Harold Wilson and I think it's
worth saying that many of the things
that happened that changed that we now
take for granted only came about because
that generation said you know we are not
going to take this and we particularly
will not have this for our children we
cannot talk about the Windrush
generation without reference to the
relationship with the police with Law
and Order and and and the rights that
took place on a number of occasions in
this country quite clearly the police in
this country have have come a long way
from where they were some would suggest
they're not quite where they need to be
just yet but but to describe to me
you'll spoken to to so many people about
this to describe to me the way in which
the police were viewed by that
generation to start with it initially at
least well I think that the um
straightforward answer is that they were
the enemy I mean when I was a teenager
in my in my 20s the basic view of pretty
much everybody in the community that I
lived in in London was that the police
assumed that you would be up to
something because of the skin you were
in and it didn't matter what age you
were at whether you were wearing a dog
collar you know the the Archbishop of of
York John sent him who got stopped I've
been stopped by the police in every
single car I've owned at every level up
to the point when I'm in like I was in
my 60s and um the the words the the
phrase that I used to use and then if
they still use it is ic3 and you would
hear on the police radio I've got an ic3
claims he's got this car can you check
it out all of us
grew up with that I think things are not
quite as egregious as they used to be
but I think that alongside the many
um undesirable attitudes that we've seen
exposed recently in police forces
particularly towards women there is
still an underlying idea that black
people are probably likely to be doing
something a bit naughty and that if you
stop one of them
um you're probably likely to find some
drugs or find them in in some illicit
activity now
that is a match of police culture
policing culture and I'm a great
supporter of for example the new
commissioner of the Met who basically is
doing the right thing which is saying to
everybody if you
if you think that they're gonna fire you
and he's actually doing it and I think
in the end that's the only way that's
going to change that the people who
believe that kind of thing should not be
wearing the uniform
[Music]
all of Britain to understand
to learn something off the history of
why we're here how we came to be here
what our part was what our contribution
Britain would not be the Britain it is
today without our contribution so it's
vitally important that we remember that
we learn that we educate each other
[Music]
I came to London and I was gobsmacked by
the amount of racism that I saw in an
almost daily basis just casual racism
left right and center and you we've just
been talking you know of course about
about stop and search I mean it's it's
no coincidence of course in the past
couple of days we have heard that the
Home Secretary swella bravman talking
about the possibility of ramping that up
as a as a means of combating crime again
I mean you are in a better position to
describe the levels of racism that exist
in this country than this pasty white
man of course you are and and I and I
wonder what your view is I mean have
have we truly made as much as much
progress as some of the politicians
would like us to believe have we made
progress yes I think actually I think we
have I mean look a couple of things
worth saying people rightly get angry
about some acts that are carried out by
people in uniform or indeed people in
schools and so on I don't want to
minimize it but at some level
we Factor all of this into our lives you
know if you talk to some people they
they I remember somebody saying to me
not too long ago that he still makes a
calculation that if he's going on a
certain route he needs to add 10 minutes
because he thinks he might be he's
likely to be stopped by the the cops in
his car and it's it's one of the things
that burdens that you bear it shouldn't
be there but if what you do if you spend
your whole life thinking about what
somebody else is going to do to you you
never come out of your house the fact
that um somebody like you is ready to
call it out is completely different to
where we were even 15 20 years ago where
actually people would excuse these
things they or they'd say why are you
getting so well enough about it and so
on so I think that also has changed
things dramatically I mean I think
you've got as much right to to talk
about these issues as I have because
race relations is about relations it's
not about one side only and and also the
truth of the matter is you are going to
know much better than I do what is said
when I'm not in the room and what people
are thinking when I'm not in the room
the word these days is allies isn't it I
I think that the role of allies the role
of people saying you know that's
unacceptable is much much more important
than some of the things we think of how
does it make you feel though that there
will there will certainly be young
people younger people out there today
for whom you know they associate the
wind rush they still say the word
Windrush immediately with the suffix
Scandal Suffolk yeah the the the the
actions of the home office that that so
unfairly treated so many people I would
regret it if this next Generation came
to think of Windrush purely as yet
another story of victimhood if Windrush
simply became yet another tale of what
white people did to black people in
which we black people are based
basically just sort of hapless
bystanders while some other people exert
their power over us I think that would
be the wrong lesson to draw here what do
you is the legacy of Windrush there's
the people getting on for a million
people of mixed race who
are a very special group of people you
know my children are amongst them and
it's very unusual you know there are not
many countries that have a mixed race
population of that size or
proportionately that big the other
countries one might mention of South
Africa where they're very separate caste
they are bris in Brazil where they are
segregated society and the United States
where actually there's no real not
really any such thing as a mixed race
person in the United States if you up
until 1967 legally if you had one drop
of black blood as it was called you know
one remote African ancestor you were
considered black
this is the only country where both in
the culture and legally it's always been
the case that somebody who has a white
parents and a black parent
can be hold both of those identities
equally and claim both of them now
we don't quite know what that feels like
I certainly don't
um and we don't quite know because this
is a new generation it's a new group
when I come back to write the story in
2048 when I learned to be 95.
um I think I'll be most interested to
see how those people deal with being
uh in on both sides of their Heritage
and speaking both languages and feeling
at home in both groups as many of them
already do I think that's fascinating I
think if we can show the world that it
is possible for people to move from one
place to another to become part of the
new population uh new new place but also
change that place in a way that
Caribbean britons have changed this
country then I think we can send out a
great message to the world that new
people different people don't have to be
a threat you don't have to treat them
with suspicion but that actually they
can bring something new to you and that
in a sense after time there won't be
them and US they'll just be us I think
that's the Legacy that this particular
group I think has brought to Britain and
I hope potentially to the world Trevor
has been an absolute pleasure having you
on the Sky News Daily thank you so much
for joining us as always Leo great to
talk to you thank you
that's a lot for this edition of The
Daily with me Neil Patterson my thanks
to Sir Trevor Phillips and you can watch
his full documentary Windrush and us on
Sky News YouTube channel this Edition
was produced by soiler Apparition our
editor is Adam J